في اسمها تبدو دوره عاديه للجامعه العربيه
دوره تحمل الرقم 32 في سياقها والحضور لا
تبدو كذلك بعد 12 عاما يحضر الرئيس السوري
للمره الاولى قبل هذه الاعوام قررت
الجامعه العربيه تجميد عضويه دمشق حينها
كانت الازمه في سوريا قد اندلعت وتحولت
حربا غيرت شكل البلاد طرحت العوده السوريه
الى مقعدها تساؤلات عما تغير في المشهد
السوري يفتح جلوس الاسد بين القاده العرب
الباب واسعا على عناصر مهمه واسئله عن
المرحله المقبله كيف سيصار الى حل ازمه
اللاجئين والنازحين الذين يقدرون
بالملايين جراء ما حل في بلادهم تساؤلات
عن اعاده الاعمار وسط بنيه تحتيه مدمره
وكذلك تساؤلات عن امكانيات اخراج قوات
اجنبيه من البلاد تحولت سوريا خلال
السنوات الماضيه الى قاعده عسكريه كبيره
بفعل الحرب دول كبرى في العالم والاقليم
وضعت جنودها الارض السوريه بعضها يعارض
النظام واخرون قاتلوا الى جانبه وتحولت
سوريا الى ساحه صراع اقليمي في ملف اللجوء
اكثر من خمسه ملايين او ستمائه الف سوري
غادروا حدود بلادهم الى تركيا والاردن
ولبنان بدرجه اساسيه استقبلت اوروبا مئات
الالاف من اللاجئين السوريين نزح اكثر من
سته ملايين الى مناطق لا تخضع لسيطره
النظام يعتبر كثير من السوريين العوده الى
بلادهم الان كابوسا وقد تعالت الاصوات
اليمينيه في بعض الدول بضروره اعاده
السوريين الى وطنهم
[موسيقى]
هناك حيث قتل اكثر من 400 الف سوري بينهم
اكثر من عشرين الف طفل
[موسيقى]
عوده سوريا الى مقعدها في الجامعه العربيه
تلفت الانظار الى وضع البلاد استعاد
النظام السوري خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه السيطره على اكثر من سبعين في
المئه من الارض الا ان اعاده الاعمار وصلت
الى طريق مسدود بعد ان اقتربت فاتورتها من
400 مليار دولار بحسب التقديرات السوريه
والروسيه شبكه الكهربائي وامدادات الوقود
والمياه والمدارس والمستشفيات كلها تضررت
بنسب متفاوته لكنها اصبحت في حكم المعدومه
بحسب مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون
الانسانيه لا شريكا به يرفض الرئيس السوري
التدخلات الخارجيه في الشؤون الداخليه
للدول العربيه هكذا يقول في كلمته ويميز
بين الحضن والانتماء
اما سوريا فمضيها وحاضرها ومستقبلها هو
العروبه لكنها عروبه تما لا عروبه الاحضان
فالاحضان عابره اما الانتماء فدائم بعد
عوده بشار الاسد لمقعده بالجامعه العربيه
تطرح التساؤلات ايضا في هذه المرحله عن
امكانيه الحوار الداخلي بين المكونات
السوريه هل يمكن ان يفضي الى تفاهمات بعد
كل هذه السنين